welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm delighted to be joined by Andrew
Dean who is the co-founder of a
recruitment business called Menlo Park
recruitment and they are a health care
recruitment recruitment brand that are
based in Leeds with 20 people in the
business and come September have been
going for five years so Andrew thank you
for joining me
remotely today how are you yeah I'm good
yeah thanks very much for having me
never never done this before so yeah
excited to EWTN's have a job yeah
awesome honestly I don't think I'd say
95% of people that commonest have never
done it before so you're not alone on
that one and where where I always like
to start on on this podcast Andrew is
how did Andrew Dean into the lovely
world of recruitment let's start with
that story yeah well I suppose like most
people you know by complete accident you
know I did archaeology and it was a
museum after finishing so you know I
suppose it's quite quite a different
start to a lot of people but yeah when
when I started you know similar
environment to today in the sense that
we're going into recession would have
been founded in a ok ended up being in
that job probably a little bit longer
then I probably anticipated and but but
really I didn't know what to do because
you know I - that I had also signed up
to do my law conversion and well I was
going to be a solicitor and then
literally a couple of weeks having paid
the fees as I oh my god I don't want to
be a really yeah so orders you at this
point and so at that point I'd have been
22 yeah you just really caught in that
what the hell do I do
yeah you know I think it's one of those
things you know you don't really get a
lot of air whilst you why are you going
through the education system and
what you want to do what you want to be
but I did kind of have in the back well
you know I've done well it's a lure a
level I didn't necessarily you know one
study at the Greeks and you could do the
conversion of course therefore you know
do something different do the conversion
course and yeah by the time I got there
you know I don't know obviously thinks
it's you know changed for me kind of
like mentally you were to do that
anymore I had some connections with you
know Harry Harrogate museums and ants
from my time study geology so I went
there and was there about eighteen
months as I said I you know probably
hadn't intended to be there yeah and
then certainly after you know a few
months there it was very much you know
applying for stuff and you know not been
a very buoyant economy and not been a
lot of stuff going and but ever yeah I
eventually applied for a recruitment job
and part of the attraction was it was
actually in Harrogate still I was like
well yeah you know I think Harrogate
I know area though niche in the respect
that it was you know it was off
care-related
and you know her family members that
work in health care and I thought okay
that sounds in a pretty interesting so I
had spoken to some people have been you
a generalist before a bit more kind of
high street it never really appealed to
me but this did then it was pretty well
written advert and yeah I went for it
and went for everything he was about
three or four stages and this company
were growing at the time as well and it
would have been probably December 2009
issue by this point and didn't get it
okay
it went someone with their with more
experience at the time which felt a
little bit um you know deflating and I
thought I'll never hear from these guys
again back to the drawing did you want
the job what's that did you what you did
you want the job that you want to yeah I
think yeah I did I did at that stage and
you know but um you know I didn't get it
and I thought I'm not gonna hear from
these guys
and I thought well you know I've been
looking for a few things come for an
interview process I was getting married
in May 2010 so when it you know when
2010 arrived it wasn't really that long
before then so a lot it Michael in other
words we're going into that yeah
and literally the week before my wedding
I got a call and was the Operations
Manager
from this company saying you know you
want to meet we might have a vacancy so
I literally met them in Harrogate pub
the week before was getting married and
you know they offered me the job then in
there I'm Axl but yeah and it's in and
out and I started yeah so you had to
deal with a bit rejection of strata the
gate before you even enter the word
recruitment yeah yeah but I suppose the
nice thing about it as well is that you
know a lot of people sometimes you know
they're here oh you know we'll
definitely be in touch yeah you know
they probably think all that that's that
you leave everyone happen never happens
and it was a nice life lesson in that
sense that but it did happen okay cool
so just to sort of set the scene in
context for everyone so then you work to
that business for was like four or five
years I think yeah so I see ended up
working therefore considering is your
first recruitment job a real long long
periods real silly still and then after
that you then and started Menlo and your
own recruitment business been apart yeah
nothing okay cool so pretty much over
the decades it's been your own business
for half of it and some working for
someone else for the first month yeah
yeah absolutely and I think you know
continuity you know I don't get where
you see people you know bouncing one
yeah you know company and even sometimes
you know sectors to the to the next I
don't get how you can you know build
your skill
establishing Network you know all those
types of things I suppose
and I'm quite a loyal person as well you
know do you get my you know my head down
you know if I tried buying two things on
you know a positive kind of you know
person and I and obviously that that set
you know influenced me kind of like
staying whatever I did as well but you
know I think it's important in
recruitment you were you know fine
somewhere you know and give it a good go
yeah I think that definitely I think you
definitely recruitment is a game where
you want you want to give it as long as
possible to as you said locally yeah
build your network building your skills
or whatever it's not a job where you go
there for six months and like yeah I'm
like okay this isn't for me on to the
next recruitment job it's yeah um okay
so those first five years then did you
did you just follow the typical route of
Andrew joined as a training consultant
or a consultant and then sort of built
your way up then to becoming the leader
and manage your team or how well yeah
essentially yeah number you know you
don't get you don't get one site you
don't get paid a lot working in a museum
okay really competitive so the salaries
on much so um you know I didn't secure
like a massive in terms of the you know
the salary that that's fair enough when
I joined but nearly attraction was
obviously you know the commission of
Commission yeah mission scheme in
hindsight but to me was you know bloody
amazing to have the opportunity to you
know more and one of the things well you
know as I was trying to negotiate I'm
just a little bit when I first you know
went in there and said we'll actually
we'll put something into your contract
and if you build you know X amount
within you know two months we'll give
you this if you do this within six
months world will increase it to this
yeah and and I went in and I think you
know I triggered the maximum kind of
like increase which was like a five
grand increase in salary within within
three months
I've been there and then after about you
know six months of being there actually
took responsibility for managing the
division really six months yeah so
overseeing the you know the consultants
that were you know in that team how big
was a business wasn't massive business
it was growing so when suppose I had
responsibilities for about you know
three or four consultants you know some
of which were you know there before I
there and a couple that weird that we'd
added another cialis you know still you
know what the learning at that point
myself you know you look back and crikey
yeah that was actually quite quick but
and be I enjoyed that I it was
completely different to you where you
know obviously the environment I've been
in previously yeah astok the you know
hard work you have got got recognized in
you know by being able to kind of like
yeah and decisions being made you know
quicker so so what at the time not
knowing you know what I know now you
know I just kind of like took as much on
yeah I was gonna I was gonna say so like
I guess what I'm interested in before we
sort of move on to sort of your own
business is like what why what and Reid
Dean managed to do that because I think
a lot of a lot of people want to be able
to progress that quickly or want to be
able to yeah hit those triggers as
quickly as possible so what why did
Andrew come from working in the museum
never obviously works from cribben
before and so what why you why did you
manage to get to that position why did
you just just hard-working when you're
you know when you're really on in your
career you know you know you stuck in
you know you don't have life you think
competition have or the skills and
however what you can control is how hard
work you know and eventually you know
you you can out learn the competition
because out learning at work and
outlasting the competition though you
the first of those things you can do is
is literally a you know work really hard
and
how do you work the most people expected
a steal learn and by doing that and by
being you know successful you can you
know eventually then you know at last
the competition and you know become a
really you know fantastic
you know consultant but it's about just
getting kind of like stuck in not being
self the fetus in relation to where to
new things but just actually giving it a
go because yeah you know it in
recruitment you think a lot about the
competition is you they obviously the
next agency okay maybe even you know
some some teammates sometimes if there's
a you know good healthy rivalry but you
know a lot of the time you know your own
competition is is you and your mindset
and and I've seen a lot of me consult
just defeat themselves or you know you
can see them making an excuse not to
pick up the phone yeah
you've just got to get you know stuck in
and go for it the you and whether that
what did you learn that from someone
around you or was that just your mindset
going into it you know I mean where
where did you call where did you do that
happen quite naturally what where did
you cultivate that was the only one
influence and that in terminate for you
to now I mean I think you know I always
have it comes from you know from from
within I'd always have always been
pretty kind of you know disciplined you
know when it came to were you know
school revision so right it was
discipline that I love yeah vision it
was discipline definitely yeah yeah it's
yeah I think you just kind of like you
know came from from within and and I
suppose you know where where where I was
you know as I was kind of here twenty
five by this point you know actually
wanted to you have to do some things I
got here as well you know not wanting to
you where to the average but actually
you know really good and be recognized
for good you know and obviously that
that comes with the Billings but you
know comes with the progression as well
so I like that and I like been you know
you know like that status as well okay
so from 6 months someone's then did you
did you continue to grow that team or
what just give me a bit of context on
that so from that so yeah so I did and
yeah continued with with with that
market for maybe another you know six
months as well okay and then in in in
addition to that instead of you know I
had the chance set up another division
within the company as well so I set up a
new division and then was essentially
you know overseeing the 32 different
sectors okay
I was the next stage of progression and
it went from being a consultant role to
more of a kind of you know business
manager so idea role so where say yeah
wasn't wasn't doing as much kind of you
know full-on you know 360 consulting
work you know a new business development
yeah and then and then having the right
people in place to help you support
deliver the roles and get them not to
speed with the client stuff as well yeah
and I mean the hours work rate was it
was very kind of you know they had very
strange hours so the contracted hours
8:30 Monday to Thursday why because the
well the idea was that you know you'd
speak to people after they finish a
finished work so it was it you know it
was back then as Weiss spoke wasn't
given the you know the flexibility on
the technology technology to be flexible
so all those conversations really did
happen in the office um yeah and was
that he never got him for that time and
I was traveling from your time as well
so you know you'd get in it you know
10:00 and you know from half I still
half a you really be hammering the
phone's you know working short lists and
doing candidate registrations etc so
you've been from from 10 you'd you know
pick up the phone somebody at 8:30 and
register them I really want to get their
the profile doing and everything like
yeah
you know half nine ten getting bacteria
to your calf off ten eleven so it was
pretty kind of you know when yeah pretty
pretty intense and yeah might kind of
fini first child with uh suppose you
know on the way in twenty twelve so
moving to the business manager role also
gave me a bit more flexibility ability
uh you know because I mean you know
doing those kind of hours with with with
it with a with a baby yeah that's tough
kind of impossible and it just you know
I speak on to that but it was one of it
you know one of the things that the
perhaps weren't great or as a company in
terms of new flexibility or thinking
around you know a situation or to make
things more flexible if we are talking
ten years ago so the same technologies
obviously didn't exist yeah look yeah
okay so how do you always want to start
your own business then I I don't know
I'd always wanted to when I knew would
always wanted to kind of like connealy
teams I've never really you know
especially your on I'd never really
thought yeah I'm gonna you know have my
own my own business that I think it was
yes only in my head the first you know
couple of years of yeah of working yeah
so where did the idea of Menlo Park and
recruitment come about then how did that
happen so you start this for context you
started with a business partner one
other person yeah so so basically you
know I I nearly left the year the
company I worked for in 2013 yeah you
know it got to the point as like mmm-hmm
you know I'm not enjoying it anymore
I've reached a certain level it's time
for me to see where to move on and I did
you know go interview somewhere else I
just you know just had the wanting to
again I targeted very kind of initiative
accompany somewhere that was actually
gonna be quite close to home as well and
then they were a decent company and I
got off it and I got a fifty know quite
a substantial
you know increased words go there that
maybe was at the time because I you know
obviously went back and explained that
you know I interviewed and I was gonna
be handling my notice in and like a lot
of people do you know the better or
worse accepted a counteroffer you did
yeah yeah well again you know not one
thing to bad-mouth but it wasn't
something that this company were great
with and that's something that I've
learned to be in our committee and what
I mean by that is you kind of had to you
really push the hand into you know any
increases to working conditions you know
anything like that it what it wasn't
very practically given sure given its me
they you know they kind of they gave me
counteroffer I've accepted that you know
he's an individual I was all well you
know I was also heading up a team at
that point as well so I think I was
really kind of you know emotionally
bought into you were two other team
members and things like that
and you know if I hadn't have accepted
the counteroffer my father being where I
am now um because my co you know I
wouldn't have had as long working with
my my business partner okay this father
came from from the same company in the
end so yeah if if I was staying as a
consultant then I should have gone but
in terms of my roots
you know it's led me to be where I am
where I am now
so I think after that point when you
count all the think things are never the
same yeah it's just it's just a bit
weird it's a bit weird and meant
mentally for you they're they're never
the same because there are reasons you
were moving in the first year don't
magically go away you know yeah up to
that point it's not a superficial
received official reason and money is
just a band-aid doesn't yeah for sure at
all so so a lot of the I think what
happen really from from that the last
kind of like two years with the company
those things you know began see where to
manifest and I suppose as my experience
was increasing you know maybe I just got
to the point where I was confident for
all actually
you know you know I think I can I can do
it myself
yeah you know i I've been working as a
consultant now for the time it was yeah
that happened three years in so if I
timing it took you know four years yeah
you know I've got a you know I've got a
skill set now I've learned certain
things and there are things that I could
change if I had my own company I'd be
able to you know to actually enact those
things and I suppose it was after that
that I started thinking about my own
company okay cool
so then what what was what was the game
plan because I think because I think I
think that that's the part I always say
it but that's the part that I think
people might worried about their mind or
some people that may get to that point
and mass time where you got to and never
take the leap never take this might be
because they don't have got on their own
or just because they're most worried
about that first year and and what they
can actually achieve so I guess yeah
what was the what was a game plan I
think what I've what I've noticed from
looking at your business and company
like you guys are clearly very proud of
of the niche that you're in I know
hopefully the intro is healthcare
recruitment brand but clearly you
focused and had an itch on the tops of
people and businesses you're gonna work
with you know guess what what was the
game plan then to start Menlo Park
what about melon yeah well it was you
know you've got to do your you know judo
you can't just one day decide you're
gonna do it and then you don't strike me
as that person yeah so you've got to you
know think about it really you know so
someone evening you know evenings and
out of work became I think right so to
help you it's basically writing your
business plan yeah and making sure you
know you can you know quite information
you know you need you know what you're
gonna do in terms of you know CRM
systems data advertising you know
technology and luckily you know had the
family friend he was mighty it
is kind of you know Withers right from
the beginning there was a massive hell
because thinking in terms of how
embryonic we work it would've been
impossible to go to an IT company
because it'd just been too expensive a
regular IT company but working with
someone like this as well he was also
you know much younger than me actually
and he was just like really exciting you
know he felt actually part of the team I
was this for so it was this - this is
the IT and tech side of things soccer I
think sometimes that's where you feel
most vulnerable because ya know that you
don't know you know you're not very
proficient beyond obviously using a
laptop and whatever for work you can
feel quite vulnerable you know an
antenna obviously it recruits his
friends so having having him from from
the start was was really important so so
really we had you know all the
ingredients that we knew right okay when
we start on day one you know we can do
this and start running it as a mini
business and we will and again that were
discipline we had that right from the
very beginning as well like we gave
ourselves holiday allowances and hours
of work you know right from the very
beginning even though we were working
from my business partners you know flat
from his flat in in Leeds because you
know literally as I started this as well
you know I had a three-year-old and a
newborn baby so it was well I was that
was that a bit was that was that a big
part of it like the the sort of other
know if there was a tipping point or
because I said it on the phone before we
did this I've heard you hear a lot that
a lot of people have that sort of
internal dialogue of light right-hander
if I'm gonna do this yeah I'm probably
gonna be able to there's not be another
time we have to do this if I don't do it
now you'll have another child and bring
another life into your family yeah I
think a lot of person people maybe
wouldn't have done it at that time when
they had a brand-new and my my wife had
reduced her hours at work as well you
choose a teacher so in some ways it was
not a great time to do it because it
involves a lot of risk you know you know
we even kind of went
and petition the small business they
never had any funding or any external
funding over then this small business
line that I had to know personally and a
lot of you know part of our business
name was obviously you know some of the
equipment but a little bit of a as well
yeah literally with nothing I didn't
have savings and things like that to
words fall back on at the time so it was
a big risk to where to do it when we did
but there was obviously preparation that
went into it as well but you know in
terms of mindset there was I never
remember you know feeling oh my gosh you
know that this is what am i doing this
isn't gonna work so I think would you
know just if it was really exciting I
work quite well under pressure which is
why like even recently it's been quite
exciting but in a weird way
you know just everyone getting that
locked in and it was it was a very
exciting time
you know you against the rest of the
yeah if against this you know company at
the time that weren't been see kind to
us in space is understandable to a
certain extent but yeah it was yeah it
was just exciting and you know just kind
of like just just just went with it
really and didn't overthink it and yeah
which we put on the phones you know we
just had a couple of laptops couple of
phones you know started making calls you
know literally didn't have a you know
active database and lots of headhunting
people I didn't really have to what was
the crack with the covenants and stuff
like that did you was the plan to build
out a new market or well there was one
there there was some you know we were
going into marketing of my colleague
never worked with my colleague was
familiar with but basically you know
we're now going into any kind of like
new was you know we felt they do they've
been a breach of contract and therefore
you know certain restrictive covenants
didn't apply in terms of being able to
actually blow enough well you know what
we did and however we did have to be
very careful you know in the the first
you obviously we didn't take any
information with us yeah of course
Aitor we didn't work with any clients
that were or anything like that so we
were starting absolutely scratch
from from scratch yeah absolutely okay
cool so how how did that first ye go
then that it goes so in line with the
business plan because I think did it
help them that you I'm assuming you
going through that process of the
lighten meant that you had had to have a
pretty had to have a pretty decent
business plan to showcase and talk about
what your plans were or whatever yeah it
was ridiculous yeah the local kind of
like leads and they literally kind of
like you they want to know your
household budget to literally how much
milk you a week so because I don't think
many people would go to that level when
did you go I mean so I think that's it I
am so so yeah you had to go into the
details just to go through that process
so they were so impressed it's kind of
like you know go for it very early on
and I supposed you know helped got you
thinking about you know you know budgets
and things like that so but yeah it was
it was definitely kind of eye-opening
but again you know it was a new chapter
as well so all of these things were also
new so it was it was exciting
I don't know you know it was all fresh
so how did you enter she then was it
just still you and your business partner
in this flat or that well then so we
were kind of like getting going you know
in the latter half of you know what
would have been and actually we'd would
earn enough where we felt we could move
into offices by February ok so you know
not that long after really you know for
four months you know ruin offices you
know small small office obviously and
yeah that the first of many in that
particular building we've had six office
moves now okay well in the same location
but you know been flexible enough
riskier sure as we've as we've expanded
so yeah we were literally you know
during that first year up until the
sorry even after that we were only in
that office for maybe like four or five
months before we went to the bigger
office
where we were bringing on some some temp
staff to you it's out with some projects
and then that was really when we hired
our first person we brought their you
know cooler temps in to help with it
take some some work of our hands and you
know one of the year the temps became a
full-time member of staff our first yeah
it was just obviously you know flexible
for his rather than here icon you know
because he it was more kind of like
project he work anyway we didn't need it
and so we just needed you know some hand
like sourcing and in the legwork on yeah
yeah I've done isn't it instead of yeah
yeah yes yeah we went through an agency
and these people obviously yeah you know
a lot of them air you know University
students who were kind of like in
between things they once it worked out
for both parties but yeah one of the
chaps we we took on Natori was finishing
his a-levels and wanted to get into
where to recruitment weirdly so maybe
there are actually some people that
choose to go yeah but yeah he started as
as admin for us so we're yeah in in the
summer of 20 2016 and that was our first
permanent member of staff and by that
point year in our our second office okay
cool so then and just to help me out as
what is it is it all palm that you do or
is it plan man contract or the game in
terms of primary care yeah to date that
is all okay yeah okay cool so then I
guess just to help me out then so I
guess so how well did you do against
your plan then so like revenue-wise away
how did you actually do in your first
year because it seems from the way
you're talking about blob of light
you'll clearly someone that had the
mindset to the rise to the occasion you
you thrived you it was exciting you
hasn't you had a real strategy to know
exactly how much can we spend on war but
I guess how yeah how did you finish it
at first year well you know the first
year I suppose anything was going to be
a bonus but for two of us
we did your shy 400 okay
that's awesome the shooter in an office
in Lee yeah I mean you know do you
expect that did you it did you really
did you really think you know what we I
don't know if you had those numbers
before or whatever but like do you know
I mean did you think that was possible
no I didn't really I mean it was again
it was such an unknown obviously you
know we had been shackles honors within
that first year but yeah you know my
business bonus that you know probably
the best recruitment consultant I've
ever seen and you know remains a you
know 360 you know his director duties to
work in to this day so - you know
massively helped having someone that was
you know absolutely fantastic and you
know I actually come back ticking
because I'd not been consulting yeah
yeah so I was coming back to it so so
for me was that the new sector and you
know 360 consulting again so we'd be
yeah you know obviously had the you know
the support of someone else and that was
crucial you know during that first year
I can't imagine people doing it on their
own atmosphere really really tough but
so but yeah having someone like like him
you know was was great and you know we
had that element of it but yeah I
started to do stuff that didn't get
chance to do you know when I was working
for this other company and if there
weren't things like lunch breaks but you
know starts go out for the run on a
lunch it was just there just a nice
things creeping in like that and that
camaraderie and just you know starting
to get bit of it and get a bit of
exercise during the middle of the day
and things like that so you said yeah
the first year was really exciting and
yeah and you know you seem like anything
was a bonus it seemed like you've just
being able to still be doing it was a
bonus yeah that's awesome so you just a
really good perspective grateful and
just really err yeah that's awesome
yeah because anything could have
anything could have gone wrong we could
have been stopped from doing just for
yeah flat and then it would have been
like oh my gosh what the wallet what
happened that he didn't plan for we
didn't expect in that first year before
we move on to the end
in any challenges or anything sort of
happened that wasn't quite in the
business plan that you had to overcome
or had to deal with it's yeah it's hard
to think back and really think what what
didn't happen because a lot of it you
have you kind of start but you just kind
of it's quite organic can you use fear
the flow to a certain extent than just
you know grinding it out so I suppose it
yeah it went you know the only thing
just went quicker than then I thought it
would yeah yeah but you know the the
thing that what was the hardest thing
was it would you did feel that you were
kind of something could happen that you
could be stopped or something so you
operating under a you know a shadow and
at the time you made me don't you know
realize it but you are I think you are
quite stressed yeah doing that so so
yeah that's probably think that you know
I didn't think about just how long it
would kind of you know you know feel cuz
it didn't you first year we really
wanted to get to that first year get
that under our belt and and not under
the same kind of you know restrictions
[Music]
that we had Bing and so that was
something that you know you perhaps
don't think about when when you go and
get started because you then having to
you know live it every day sure um so so
yeah that's why it's a so I guess final
point then served for people listening
that want to take that lead not sure I
guess what knowing what you know now
what would you say to people that are
saying would be talking to and I'm
thinking about stammering recruit
members business blah blah blah like
know what you know now what yeah what
would you say to these people you know
you you've got to be you've got to be
prepared you know there there has to be
some you know semblance of a plan and I
think at a time when we started you know
the within our particular sector you
know primary care and it was still it
was still quite new as a market and in
terms of permanent recruitment and
use a market you know justjust surgeries
not being used to it so it was still you
know it was still a niche there was
still a gap there for someone like a do
to exist so I think you've got a you
know if you want to be you know
successful you've got to you know choose
something that where there is demand for
it yeah well even it where you can sell
sell you services you don't make sure
you've got a plan and and just be as
disciplined as you can and so like I
said you know earlier we you know you
know we're working for a flat we had you
know structure right from the very off
you know we had working hours you know
she had you had you had the I think this
has come up a lot it's like you had you
had you in your business pot and I had
the mindset of light have yet in place
and now rather than when we get in the
office will have hours and yeah yes yeah
so essentially we were operating like a
business even though we weren't this
yeah bones and yeah right from the very
beginning we were operating like yeah
like a business yeah and I think that
that yeah I think that that mindset
tomtom again I hear that nothing that's
this if it's the better way to approach
it rather they're not when we get when
we move out of here we'll do this and
we'll stop doing this but in there was
you then - I'd like to perhaps isn't it
yeah habits and also yeah yeah help so
okay cool so I guess so then what after
that first year then hit that milestone
what what was the when did you start
hiring people like what was the the
growth plan for the business then like I
machine had you in the business pond
always for this is never gonna be just
menu in in the flat obviously we've got
the office like what was the could you
then have a growth strategy for the
business well again that was that was
quite organic so that was the the summer
of 2016 with the admin person and then I
suppose you know we're getting to the
point where is like yeah we've got a lot
of we've got a lot of business on and
you know we could you know giving more
ground here but yeah one of the first
things we did we want to just recruiting
GPS at the time and we knew there was
obviously a market for allied health as
well so
you know advanced nurse practitioners
artists nurses medical pharmacists etc
so so that was something we weren't
doing so we thought you know you can
bring someone in to focus on that
we obviously then you're mopping up some
business that we're just not seven
looking at it not looking about yeah
those things that we did strategically
and then the I suppose the second hire
after that came on that side of things
as well to add an additional team member
to where to Allied Health again giving
us you know more coverage have been able
to split the job with me and so the
rebel token of a drill go deeper and
extract more revenue from the center
okay how did you get these people to
join in because what it's you free in
the office and leads
yeah well very very early on we relied
on people that we had once known okay
phone either they've gone and done
different things so they were working
with with different companies now and
that we stayed in touch with so it's a
very early on I suppose that was the
easiest thing to work to do and in the
sense that there was you know some some
trust there yeah
the risk element was was less to were to
a certain extent especially seen as we
knew that we could theoretically work
with them and that we yeah and that we
had done so you know once upon a time so
so they were the yeah they're the first
kind of hire that allowed us to you know
bring in some additional team members
okay cool and then I guess what I'm
always keen to sort of them speak to me
about and ask is one of the most common
things that people want to know about is
I guess but how
when did you start breaking because what
the questions that I get a lot is he
should model every to sort of speak to
business owners on how they push past
that sort of 10 head mark or that 15
head mark milestone because I think that
that I mean 80 percent of the UK
recruiting industry is sub 10 staff in
terms of criminal business sighs I think
it's really common where real criminal
in Caesar will get around that sort of
ten or twelve head mark and then they'll
hire someone then they'll and then
someone will leave and they always sort
of fluctuates in that I guess understand
early on use your network your resources
has been
Organic but I guess how did you then go
back because I'm sure your business then
looks quite different when you're
pushing pot heads like you know how did
that all plan out on sort of learnings
there I guess the next stage
yeah was was start we'd had some of that
were obviously we think with attempts
and but the next stage really on the
permit side of things yeah we were then
taking that leap into making hires where
we simply didn't know the people so
again you just got a organize and have a
robust process you know you are kind of
like hiring but you you want to be you
want to be formal with it and make sure
that you trying to get right first time
of asking and I think what I've been
able to do and then the other than basic
I've got a 100% success rate so far
every interview we've had and where we
wanted to offer
we've got 100% acceptance on that really
yeah in five years so I think I'm really
good at actually selling selling what we
do and what was your process I think
that that's a learning for a lot of
people when you're a smaller sizes it's
clearly or someone that didn't you've
had that mindset from the day one or
working on the flight you have lunch
hours blah blah blah but I think that's
where some people fall short as well as
where they don't have that process it's
more right let's go to the pub let's
have a chat bubble ass or what your
process that like from our early process
which is a bit more developed
now for example of you know psychometric
testing but it's not something we're
doing back then was simple so you know
telephone and into you because but first
we'd advertise need some roles phone so
someone is actually applying to an
advert obviously gave for a few more
stages so as the neutral stage would
have been a telephone interview
essentially with with the person if that
went well meeting them face to face and
if the face to face went well giving
them an insight day you know not the
full day but the chance to actually come
into the office you know sample the you
know the atmosphere you see the CRM
system get to go to a few things and and
I'm from there offering
[Music]
how many people they meet depends on how
big we were at that stage but but it
would be you your business partner and
other people would it be - you - yeah
yeah yeah once we got to the year to the
inside they would give them chance to go
for coffee with the people you know
we're left weird where you know the boss
invites a couple of people to meet them
but they're still then they're yeah see
them been very kind of you know
self-aware so basically just giving them
you know go off have a have a coffee and
ask any kind of questions in a more
neutral environment because you know
that's the thing about interview
processes they are very very artificial
for ya you can you can do what you want
but someone is very aware that they are
been you know interviewed and therefore
you're never gonna get the full facts
yeah just giving the opportunity because
then you get there you know the peer
feet from you know teammates as well
it's important for your again you're
just in team members to buy in - yeah
especially small or growing business
like that is so important
yeah because it because you can see
because it can be weird you know when
you're signing something I'm very small
and you're adding B connects I've been
in that situation before it's weird not
to grow as you feel a bit strange there
getting them involved in in the process
yeah whether there's a new start when
did you start introduced in the
psychometric test because again I think
it's come up a lot but how I can I think
again having that mindset of while we're
a small business we don't need to do
that it's the big corporate to do that
more and more is coming up but but how
is that impacting your processes that
really helped you to make bad decisions
as well yeah to be honest that's only
been you know this this last year it's
not something that we used to water on
it wow it's more of them and I think
well what it does with the one of the
really good things it does is it gives
you some specific questions to ask in a
face to face interview based on that
person's personality type really yeah
which is which is good so interesting
all to come in from so I think that's
one of the beneficial things it does for
us the other is if you understand the
person
a bit more from the beginning of the
process you can on board them more
effectively baseboards I love you type
as well and maybe you know if they are
struggling in certain areas related back
to where to that well based on their
best method of learning and that type of
thing so um it's it's probably something
I'd have introduced em you know earlier
if I'd have known more about it but it
is you know pretty expensive at the at
the same time but yeah it's um I think
it's definitely a good thing to wear to
do and what we'd also done as well is is
giving you a couple of our existing you
know high performance just to understand
them they're Mia what what kind of
reports they're getting back and can we
identify that and you know they come in
to interview yeah and then I think just
a final point just before we sort of
Rihanna sort of talk to you a bit about
sort of today and sort of would be not
to I guess just on the hiring and peace
because again it seems like you really
approached it in their smart way is how
what was your mentality of growing this
business was it always we're always
hiring
or did you become quite good at sort of
recognizing horan triggers in your
business so I did you did you wait until
people got to a certain point before you
start looking at getting more people in
or like what was the mentality to help
you to get I mean what was your mind
yeah on the consulting side of things I
think it was obviously it's quite
time-consuming to you to bring someone
in so there's a period do you have any
concept when you're a smaller business
where you know we've been very kind of
like hands on and I've been in your
hands on boarding and wanting to give
them a lot mission as is so you know not
spreading yourself too thin actually
getting them up and running and they're
not established before perhaps you know
taking over someone else you know
someone else and gradually giving you
know geographical territory away because
one of the things you know it's never
just going right and that's one thing
that we changed actually and because it
in my previous experience and
when you came in there basic in 30
geographical kind of like territory is
is how you be a 360 consultant both
client and candidate at the same time
and you know here's some training but
there you go
yeah that's really overwhelming for
revenue starters
Steve like literally you know 20 30
sometimes more vacancies in one go
clients they've never spoken to and
start approaching from the mentality
that I've got to go fill jobs and
there's two things wrong with that them
it gets you really kind of like job
centric and you know secondly it it also
is intimidating for you know the new
person because there's that you know
there's that pressure and here is your
business then you're going to use
revenue if you hand over these vacancies
that teasing
a long experienced consultant he changed
you know our process to make me more
candidate leads and actually you know
when someone new comes on board will
start very much on the candidate side of
things first and can the networking not
you know not even discussing job so here
is your you know eurozone broken up into
you with the different sections
yeah we'll begin by making cans of calls
within you know this part of your your
network so you're just having open
conversations with them about you know
what we do and in their requirements and
registering them and then actually
taking that candidate to market because
it gets them you know thinking in you
know in a completely different way and
yeah they're not just going oh I've got
a job his job and running a job down you
know super oh yeah they're just having a
conversation actually understanding
thing in their perspective so rather
than you know thinking you know it's a
bit more free to them to actually learn
from these people yeah can worry her
yeah it can be very linear and just your
prescriptive if you're just going in
with a job yeah if you if you got those
yeah hundred percent I think because
like that's how what my um busted air
would they come
cetera but I think I think you're right
that's really interesting actually the
if you haven't got a job in mind that at
all and you're calling these people just
because you need to be curation in to
learn about their is way yeah you're
you're right you're not thinking in your
head
right are they good for this job are
they good for that job which gives a you
a bit more freedom to just really dig
deep into and since I'm in your market
which is something really important and
then once you've got you know some
canvas you can take them to mark indeed
before it marked here and then you learn
that element of it so how you mark it
and then when you bring a job on from
that it gives you the opportunity to
actually take that that job on so you
understand it way better than if you
just inherited a job and then you can
learn the job side of the process since
then broken down several different
stages which makes it less overwhelming
for for the consultant because we we
after our initial couple of hires we did
you know hire people that have never
been in recruitment before and we
literally need them how to be a
consultant from from the very beginning
okay cool interesting so I guess let's
talk about today then Andrew I guess
probably people listening are he's fine
he's in the health care industry they
must be doing really well right now but
I guess yeah well why don't we just sort
of set the scene I guess what how what
what have you been thinking about over
the last six to eight weeks on what's
going on right now and what have been
some of the sort of decisions you've had
to make Menlo Park move forward well
it's not as simple as that because we
get the you know perception in in the
press that everywhere is just absolutely
kind of you know round and you know
you've obviously got the photos of
people sleeping on wards and stuff like
that which obviously is going on in
those wards related to um you know the
the current crisis but actually reach EP
surgeries the opposite is phone away
aren't like they are quiet you know
parents have been and stopped from going
T word to GP surgeries and actually you
know you had something to
when you've had something to product
going on and first of all for a decision
makers within Francis there was a lot of
you know obviously having to prepare and
respond to government advice so they
just weren't there to speak with and
they were busy trying to implement you
know the strength needs to happen within
but secondly with with increased tech
there you know some surgeries ascend
well this is going to solve all he's
going forwards and actually that vacancy
did have we might not need now realizing
that you know we maybe don't have the
capacity issue that we we first thought
we did have so it's that's not been the
case every but we have had an impact
from that so it's definitely not plain
sailing in terms of our sector you know
and be kpi's or near critical metrics
whatever you want to call them you know
it for the cliff when lockdown occurred
again for logistical reasons because um
I mean that would have happened for
everyone if you can't interview people
it is it is going to you were to clog
things up in particular things like the
number of terms of business of people
sending out really worse was massively
impacted yeah well I say yeah we
definitely have felt the impacts of you
know Corona and coronavirus on you know
our sector as well however you know what
I would say thankfully is that you know
it hasn't obviously you know completely
died away like some sectors and over the
last few weeks three or four weeks in
particular each week we have seen only
like to pick up a bit yeah in the KPIs
you know in key areas like no terms of
business interests first interviews etc
so we have started to see you know a bit
of recovery after the initial shock of
what was going on has them has I'm sure
again it will check its luck
ever-changing at the moment or whatever
but just as you're talking about it what
have been the sort key metrics you've
been looking at to I guess one for an
archer is that as a business owner right
now people are maybe never
work from home and they're having to
manage their business and team remotely
I guess what from your perspective what
have been the key metrics and things
you're looking at from afar that give me
a real confidence in everyone's sort of
doing everything they can they've been
they can but I guess what key metrics
are you looking at and that help you
understand where the business is at and
what's going on yeah well the first
point I'd make is that you know we don't
use the metrics to kind of like bash
people go for example we do you know a
court system where we can't see exactly
you know what calls have been made yeah
their length of call times you know etc
exception so that's that's an indicator
if you know what's going on how people
are doing length of conversation that
are having versus minutes of of call
just to see our people actually talking
to people and then it has been key
things like you know terms of business
are engaging in conversations relating
to vacancies in candidates are they
engaging in you know job opportunities
and largely they have been that that's
one thing that has kind of remained
steady or out I mean know it dipped and
then it has been in your increasing but
literally last week was the second
highest interest week on record you know
that we've had some tomorrow according
the stats in that particular way it
sounds definitely bounce back quicker
then you know the the client side of
things however we need you know we're
getting to the point now where we need
fresh vacancies on and that's going to
be the you know the challenge island
yeah so yeah they're the key things of
that and you know obviously the
interviews and the surgeries have been
having to make use of tech and we have
actually had instances of processes so
yeah actually occurring within the
coronavirus we didn't lock down from
actually that first submission to
accepting an offer also them virtually
and you know historically a lot of GP
surgeries haven't been used uptake as if
shall we say I mean I mean I always
whenever I visualize a GP I think of the
doctor where I grew up and had their
oldest computer ever had paper
everywhere yeah honestly until recent
he was still getting asked you know
faxing oh my god now that had a fax
machine we literally can't and we've
seen some some improvement there but
certainly yeah you know really processes
you know over Skype or you know yeah or
whatever and just just was just it just
wasn't done so um but obviously the
NHS's is really you know started to to
embrace that so I think is how realized
they need to were to do that you know
going forwards and you know and that has
resulted process is being able to yet
its carry on cool and then I guess like
how why have you made the decision to
because I think obviously is early on
from a recruitment industry standpoint
you may or may not have noticed it or
seen it a lot of businesses even making
a lot of redundancies or putting huge
amounts of their staff on furlough and
I'm see you've made hires during this
period for your business I guess why why
and how have you done that what's the
sort of mindset towards that because I
think a lot of people won't be having
that mindset towards and adding more
people to their business like what yvy
view approach it like that yeah it was
um I suppose it's just taking and it was
taking advantage of some of the
opportunities that the current climate
is also you know presented as well I've
got someone knocking on my window just
there just two seconds otherwise yeah
sorry yeah no stress okay yeah
that Paris yes if you say no so you
taken the opportunity to with the
current climate in terms of bringing
people bringing people yeah I mean I
I've I've had more time you know working
from from how yeah you know in the
office it's a plan people have a lot of
you know access to us so you can get
pulled into many different flow to the
day even if you have your own you know
plan so yep been working from home has
allowed me to have I suppose more kind
of focus and more time to spend on this
and you know I suppose for for some you
know for some others as well you know
for people out there it's maybe got them
thinking about you know where they are
and what they're doing as well and
perhaps them actually having a you know
more time to you would consider these
things so it's been a kind of a blend of
those two things and occurring and we
always wanted to add sectors in 2020 you
know health tech was also you know was
always a name of mine for for this year
you know adding another couple of
sectors that we just you know weren't on
the cards you know honestly they weren't
on the cards but you know been
introduced to you know a couple of
people that were you know fantastic
people that I saw a lot of you know
potentially and went through it again a
virtual process with them so I've never
met these people face to face and how
was that because I think a lot of people
are would think would they actually
accept an offer I remember I had had
someone just message me he was listening
to podcast or whatever and unfortunately
got made redundant and he's had a couple
of interviews but he said to me it was
quite experienced recruiters like he
doesn't feel comfortable accepting and
the offering to he's actually met these
people in person
and I thought which I sort of get but I
guess how did you find that and
obviously people started and accepted
jaws of you guys but like was actually
like and was what's the feedback thing
from people then that have actually
started yes yes for me wasn't you know
wasn't an issue and I think again you
know you just got to you know go with
with Andy and make the best of a
situation so you know we have got you
know video technology so we can see
someone you know either end of you know
the computer screen and and again we
were able to go through a you know
decent process so maybe added a few
extra kind of like things and there so
you gave them some specific questions to
complete your almost like a mini
business plan blood drink testing and in
the end of the day I think it's one of
those things again you know if I
recognize you know someone is is really
good I just wouldn't want to you know to
miss out on them
yeah even over you know video you can
sell the company you know well and yeah
with with the people who had clicked and
were able to do that over run what what
saw was their first week like them
remotely what about what their first
week look like they've all looks
slightly different because you know with
you know with cares it's been you know
about crying you know a database you
know you know business database and
importing that onto a CRM system so that
you know they've got that to do and one
of the biggest headaches I've had is you
know redesigning the website because
it's it's in primary care up until now
but now I've got to turn it into a you
know Africa brand Villa and and the
website we only had done you know
recently so the first week has been we
use wheezed teams so was you know I make
sure that I'm touching base with them
you know proactive course the day you
know you can screen share in terms of
you know processes and things like well
and you know use them I use a sauna on
earth
you can obviously have your your lists
on there you know share that with the
individual and update in in real time so
just been using you know technology to
to make the first weeks as smooth as
possible so we entered those weeks with
wither to-do list but obviously when I
like starting you know a new there's
there's loads just like
and stuff did it to get right and so
there was a lot of that not going on in
so I guess anyone anyone the Superbird
about that I guess it doesn't sound as
difficult as maybe some people perceive
there might be some challenges and bombs
along the way but yeah lots of all ng
the spoken see because they're yeah you
know they obviously felt comfortable
accepting pops yeah you know there might
be some people you speak to you you know
over the video that you don't so a space
it depends on the situation how much
you're for the opportunity and whether
you want to let something pass because
if you want it you know nothing you
really bought into it then you know
you'll make it happen in in the current
climate and then obviously if you don't
and you feel bit more cautious and then
you won't and the film's really whether
you've actually passed them something
that's that's really cute but I think
you've anywhere possible you just
sometimes you just gotta go for for the
things it you know I'm keen on
surrounded myself with you know really
it would be all people don't want to
work with and that stuff in your mature
and yeah identified that and knows that
we virtually virtually met progressing
with them so I guess as we sort of come
to the end of this I guess from what
what are you thinking about sort of the
the long-term effects can be of this
current period may be on you as a
recruitment business owner the industry
what what the things that are coming up
for you that you think could be
interesting or impact
yeah one of one of the cool things to
come out of this is you know just the
camaraderie that's gone within you know
this happens within the industry with
him within recruitment because yeah
sometimes I think he can be really
insular one thing it's taught me is that
a lot of people about their own
different businesses that want to help
each other sure and I've not really
experienced that you know have you
nervous had had you never sort of just
organically naturally seeked help or
offer advice I guess because it is you
to other night yeah yeah no yeah no I
mean we were again
what we're trained is every we will yeah
fantastic trainer
and you know from the British Institute
of creatures though we have there their
knowledge and their expertise of an
obviously working with you know loads of
different you know recruitment
businesses and so it's not like we're
completely in zero other things that are
going on but in terms actually speaking
directly with other recruitment
businesses that's definitely something
that I you know I didn't really do it's
because I don't know a lot of them
though so I think that that's really
cool I don't need everyone seeing
something to start working together but
you know there's definitely you know
support and a community you know out
there for recruiters and I think you
know that's been really good and I think
yeah just also you know put my cycling
what we do as recruiters is really kind
of you know worthwhile and valuable and
actually do do a really great job those
ethical continuing to wear to keep going
and you know that haven't fair those I
mean obviously some that I've had to
work further stuff but it's grinding it
out and really acting in the best way
possible and I'm working hard and nikana
me going in a really kind of like tough
times that you know in terms of what's
gonna happen obviously there's gonna be
you know anymore you know you know going
on in that that's not gonna go away in
terms of processes but also impacting on
on people's and pups as well so for what
I heard the moment I honestly can't say
how that is going to on primary care
whatever really is going to go a long
way to addressing the the shortage of
GPS that have been over the last X
number of years within primary care so
you know it could you know impact as it
could it could take away business you
know potentially yeah if the numbers of
people and you know aren't needed but
it's really difficult to say how that
will works I think a lot of that will
rely on patient the month as well and
actually how they want to interact with
with the other motor not everyone will
want to do that by a video or a screen
there so so we'll be that blended
of using it working with no patience to
figure out the best route for is but you
know I'm excited Ferb you know for
health second and medical device you
know I think I think that our eyes to
what we're doing is as well and I think
you know we yeah that's that's gonna
excel and I think it's absolutely
crucial that we're pop I'm really
looking forward to also developing that
because yes by 2030 eighty percent of
job roles will be tech and 85 percent of
roles will be you know that exists in
2030 haven't been invented yet it's
gonna be an interesting yeah 10 10 years
there's gonna be lots of weak cushions
from obviously what's what's going on
but I think you have been involved in in
tech and particularly you know health
tech is awesome you know it's going to
be interesting in terms of how that is
now used to new to shape global health
cuz it's coming here we obviously work
in the UK at the moment they only these
these new sectors will take us outside
of insulation or outside of those
borders and I think you know in general
people will be thinking more about
global health care than just you know a
country
yeah yeah that's really interesting ok
so two final questions for Andrea and
first one is what are you most excited
to do and for post covert I think I'm
really excited to see everyone again and
haven't had chance to actually properly
meet so far so I think that's going to
be really really cool because we in
April we were due to our quarterly
outing we had a couple new team members
you know scheduled for for that and
obviously was never able to you were to
happen so restrictions you know finally
easily great just to have everyone back
I mean we don't know what that's going
to look like obviously yet but
we are able to you know see see some
people I think that'll be you know
really exciting and then personally
there's just been yeah a few few things
that we've had see where to cancel you
know holidays you know seeing people
people have birthdays you know during
during lockdown so yeah you know be good
see would see some of those people that
we've not been able to you know
personally you know see you know just
give them a you know a Hogan house yeah
for sure we doing it over you know over
a video call and go out to eat somewhere
as well god I can't wait for that we had
a couple of nice meals like gone by the
wayside and send a box I mean I you know
week eight center Fox a lot but you know
the kids are really enjoying their bikes
at the moment and we had a box booked in
center parts are so good so be good to
you I can't get them back there and on
the box yeah and just some things to
look forward to in the calendar that
just aren't obviously they're totally
may it's the last question I always ask
people you could answer this with a word
the phrase a sentence whatever comes to
mind but if Andrew kids communicates
every single recruits right there they'd
listen they've taken an advice that
implements it tomorrow what what would
you say to the people I Fair listening
what would your advice be the recruiters
in general yeah have you know have hope
use it as a time to kind of reflect on
what you're doing and I think you know
going forwards work for you know a
company that you believe in I mean isn't
that you believe and if you find the
right place obviously you know things
are going to bounce back and we're not
going to be in this recession for you
know forever so I think for those there
fanuc kind of like really tough at the
moment you know keep keep going you know
keep calling your candidate clients
foster goodwill goodwill equity as I've
heard people you know refer to it you'll
be in a fantastic position for when when
things do return to normal and you know
if you've been working through this and
you have
to work twice as hard you'll be a way
better recruiter for it so you know I
think Ryan you know Britt Britt it out
you know it is tough but you know the
best lessons I learn from tough
situations mmm get out and you'll be a
way better recruiter after this you know
so just just hang in there these things
things are gonna get better yeah and I
love that and and it's been a pleasure
thanks a lot so enjoyed finding out your
story more about the business things
wicked and excited to see how it
unravels mate yeah